hey guys Pete here today we're going to
talk about dougie again in light of some
new information that came out in part 14
quick spoiler warning this will focus on
something that was said in Twin Peaks
season 3 episode 14 so if you're not
caught up it could spoil thing without
out of the way months ago after part 4
aired I did a video about dougie and
where he might have come from at the
time I expected that since the real
dougie Jones disappeared into the red
room his life would be a short stopover
point to the eventual re-emergence of
real Agent Dale Cooper now that didn't
really turn out to be the case and now
that we're getting towards the end of it
it seems clear that Cooper was destined
to live in Dougie's life for the
majority if not all of season 3 and for
the most part we haven't had any new
information on what was really going on
with his life
we did learn in part 9 that there were
no records of dougie Jones's existence
before 1997 from the free scope brother
you know the detectives also we learned
in part 5 that his wedding ring was
discovered inside major Briggs his
headless body in Buckhorn South Dakota
beyond that mostly what we've seen is
that he had a fairly normal existence
working as an insurance agent living
with his wife Janie E and son Sonny Jim
and they owes some guys money
for a football bat that apparently Jani
took care of we found out that he had
been in the car accident
or at least that was the story the
bushnell said about four he had hired
dougie and that he may have cases where
he experiences catatonia almost like
where he gets almost like how he is I
guess you could say but that's about it
all this changed in episode 14 when we
got two important pieces of information
the first was that Diane is actually
Janie
II's half-sister their estranged but she
knows that Janie II is married to
somebody named Douglas Jones who
everybody calls dougie so there is a
connection we didn't know about the
second one was a little more subtle but
we heard it when Tammy was learning
about case number one
of the Blue Rose task force from Albert
he explains to her that back in 1975
Gordon and Sol Jeffries want to
investigate a murder where a woman
basically shot herself the one that was
shot disappeared but before she died she
said that she was a blue rose
Tammy points out that the blue rose
doesn't occur in nature and that
indicated that Louis Duffy's double with
something like a Tulpa so way back in
the beginning we realized that the main
thing about dougie as far as Cooper
being stuck inside of his body was that
one way or another he was manufactured
which we hear from Mike as a decoy to
evil coop being sucked back into the
lodge but that made everything a bit
confusing and we really didn't know much
more about it
now the word told Bob comes from Tibetan
mysticism and I read a bunch about this
yesterday there's some pretty good
theories out there that are centered
around this revelation and of course
there always has been somewhat of a
Tibetan influence and Cooper has
mentioned the Tibetan method that he
uses we've seen other references related
to his character also when the Merle
mentioned the Doug pause which is
another thing the hell won't get into
here but that's also figured into a lot
of theories about what's going on over
the years and obviously David Lynch
practices Transcendental Meditation and
has an interest in Tibetan ideas as well
so Tammy coming out and saying the word
is pretty huge I think because there was
already a word that they've been using
they didn't need to use the word shilpa
they could have just said doppelganger
sure it's a little bit more specific but
to me it just seems like it was
consciously and conspicuously put in
there as a clue to what might be going
on now does it mean it's the linchpin of
everything and it'll make everything
make sense I don't think that either but
I'm saying that they made sure that they
threw that in there so make what you
will of it so what does it mean the word
tufa comes from Tibetan mythology or
Tibetan mysticism whatever you want to
say there
it refers to a thought-form a being that
is created through a person's mental or
spiritual power so it's not just an
imaginary thing it's rather a real
sentient being now when I was reading
about this there are some different ways
that it's interpreted so I'm just going
to go with that as it's because it's
simple because there may be some
distinction between topos and dreams and
then actual physical beings in the world
so yeah there was a ton of stuff that I
read that was interesting here one is
about this idea of totem answers which
is I guess how you pronounce that but
there are special people who through
focus concentration and visualization
can produce imaginary beings that they
call tupa and almost everything I read
said they're understood to be distinct
sentient beings within the world with
their own personalities inclination and
so on they're autonomous of the person
who makes them but then it gets a little
bit gray because they can sometimes meet
in imagined environments or wonderlands
dreamscapes whatever you know what call
that their and this kind of sounds a
little bit like the Red Room and other
places we've seen like where the Giants
had possibly the White Lodge and you
know the mobs on all these places so the
main takeaway is is that they use this
word this word means something that's
produced by the mind of someone but
isn't necessarily controlled by that
person but they're independent and
autonomous and can go out and do things
in the world so my thinking and some of
the stuff that I've read about this is
what dougie is isn't exactly what we
just described but he is something that
evil Cooper was able to create or
manufacture through his own mind now one
of the articles I read about this said
that there could also be some further
information about this or further
verification of this in the way that
he's able to manipulate his arm when he
arm rustles that guy like all this could
be through his own mental exertion
if you will so if we look at it through
that lens then we could say that evil
coupe manifested a Tulpa it became known
as Douglas Jones it was an autonomous
being that lived its own life developed
differently than the original Cooper
that we know and of the evil Cooper
since they all have a distinct look and
got married had a job so on and so forth
even got himself into gambling problems
and cheated on his wife they told it
right I feel pretty good about this as
being an explanation we always kind of
thought that dougie was created by evil
COO and I feel like this makes a lot
more sense than the connections that
people were trying to draw to Jack
Parsons Alastair Crawley Crowley and all
that you know I mean I think this is a
little more straightforward the only
real problem is if we accept that it
opens the door for a lot of stuff to get
weird the first thing that comes to mind
is Sarah Palmer and the theme that she
had in the last episode I mean it makes
you wonder if she's not manufactured and
at first you would say well why would
Sarah Palmer have this ability to do
that well it doesn't necessarily have to
be done by her you understand what I
mean there was a part in the scene where
Hawke was explaining the math to Frank
you know he said that there was fire but
he described it is more like an energy
or a form of you know something like
modern-day electricity like a force and
whenever Frank asked them if it's good
or bad he says it depends on the
intention so that kind of sounds like
creating stuff and I think the biggest
one is when we saw Laura Palmer being
created by the Giant or the fireman I
mean he was sort of literally floating
there thinking or focusing his mental
exertion or attention or however you
want to say it and a golden orb was the
result and it had Laura's face on it so
that all could be very confusing if we
if we let it get out of the mainframe of
Dougie's existence then we have like
Maddie who did look exactly like Laura
except she had dark hair and more
glasses more off
then we have this new guide belly that
might be the guy in jail
there's NATO who is obviously a
mysterious character what did she come
from and then we have like the source of
where we get the idea the lowest Duffy
and the fact that major Briggs has
disappeared like his head floated away
we saw that same thing with the woodsman
that was in the jail cell so there's a
lot of people that could fall under this
umbrella Philip Jeffries comes to mind
as well so it's an interesting thought I
tend to hope that it's not something
that is going to be a major factor in
understanding what's going on at the end
of the season and I have to say before I
finish this out that it's also possible
since there are tapas that are in these
Wonderland's or dreamscapes this could
be a clue that the entirety of
everything is a dream that say Cooper is
having himself or perhaps even Audrey
since we're getting strange clues about
her existence towards the end like I
said I kind of hope that none of that
the case but I'm interesting to see what
you guys think do you think that that
was thrown there because that's how Doug
Lee came into the world what do you
think that means about evil Cooper's
abilities I feel like the guy Freddie
with the green glove being destined like
having to find his destiny and Twin
Peaks is foreshadowing the fact that
that green glove may be helpful to
counteract evil coop but we don't know
for sure yet so yeah I just want to hear
all of what you're thinking about this
stuff please like the video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already make sure
you turn on notifications follow me over
on Twitter Instagram and like my
Facebook page thanks for watching guys I
will talk to you soon